all right raphael
yes sir raphael uh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally okay so i
grew up in east africa tanzania
is that right yes so
it's very interesting um you grew up
with a a mom and a dad
i grew up with a mom and dad but um
sadly my dad passed away when i was at a
young age
he was sick so he paralyzed and uh
half of his body was working the other
half was not working
so he was um he couldn't move but
yeah i mean he was my dad was different
you know my dad grew up in a in a
village
and um where he grew up he had these
different mindset because where he grew
up it was a place where
there's a lot of voodoo things happening
and then if you had like more than three
sons they'll kill
they will kill uh they'll kill the
oldest one or something like that and he
was the oldest so my grandma um
had to run away with my dad and that uh
my dad actually nickname was called misa
firi which means traveling in english
that's swahili and um
he always always um
most of the time i never even
i was never around him you know i never
spent time with him like that i remember
i knew a few moments but it was always
moving i was working
traveling
pretty much he died when you were old
when i was 15 years old i came yes
and i was at a basketball game
and uh how do you describe a childhood
in your childhood you know living in
tanzania it's going to be very different
than the united states
my childhood was was crazy just growing
up in that environment was
difficult
i mean just put it like this you know we
grew up in a place where you know
they cut your power every day
and there's nothing you can do about it
you know it's something normal you know
there's no running water you gotta
walk a few miles you know to get actual
water
you know things like that
it was never easy violence was
everywhere
but
there was not much drugs like out here
i could say that what do you what do you
make of like
you live in los angeles now yes you came
here when you were 18. i moved to
san francisco when i was 18. okay yeah
i just moved to l.a like a few months
ago so san francisco and la are not that
different
pretty much you've been us you're old
now 25 years old 25 so you've been here
for a little while yes sir
what and you've seen the homeless
communities in san francisco you've seen
them in l.a
it's really bad it's damaged
but it's it's it's similar in a lot of
ways to how people live in 10 10 really
yeah it's really similar um
at some point
not at exactly um everything because
how i said you know most people out here
are provided with uh
you know opportunities but at the same
time
you have to go and fight for those
opportunities you know are there
opportunities in tanzania i'm sorry what
was that are there opportunities in
tanzania not competitor out here
feel me i mean this is
this is la man this is los angeles
california excuse me anybody coming
outside you know third world countries
or how we call it you know the forward
both side you know it's hard you know
just
like
how let me give you my perspective
there was nothing i can do back home for
as far as anything i wanted to do with
work
basketball music
school
just
anything you want to do
youtube there's nothing there's no
opportunities like that
you know people do it but if you stayed
in africa what what would you have done
i don't know if i would have been alive
so you you're you're basketball talent i
mean i wasn't i was a critic i mean i
wasn't like you know this
good kid like you know now i was i was
troubled you know
rough
but basketball got you a scholarship
basketball gave me opportunity to go to
go schools meet you know different
teachers that had
believed in me you know
and i always loved school
a major uh i took uh
into uh international business at dvc in
san francisco
you mean
i always love business i'm a businessman
i always see myself as an entrepreneur i
have a few brands i'm opening i'm
working different projects i'm having uh
working with different people you know
different young entrepreneurs trying to
you know just
rebels that's one of my brands it's
called rough rebels you know just going
against the eyes you know because you
know
i say rebel because you know
you know the definition of rape was
going against the odds
i call it rough well first is my name is
raphael but second is cause you know we
come from these bad environments you
know it's not in our favor
feel me the environment
we grew up in just not even in africa
just it can be syria it can be pakistan
it can be
haiti it can be jamaica you know these
are rough environments this is not
america this is not the first world you
know this is third world countries this
is full you know it's full sign you know
it's now
the same and i always try to give that
to my friends my people my co-workers i
always try to put that in your head like
you know as much uh my one of my friends
said it better from new york you say
most people out here in america have
first world problems
and they don't even
recognize it
tell me tell me what it's like for a
person living in tanzania
they're they're living where in a little
shack
well
i don't want to say that tanzania is
these bad places cause
everywhere in the world
no matter where it is
there's always a place for people making
money it can be mexico or it can be
anywhere even in l.a right now people
are struggling but it's people making
money you mean
that's everyone in the world you mean
how i grew up because i'm the last the
five kids
my uh my dad had like 12 kids but my mom
he had five kids
different man
pretty much but um
how i grew up uh
it was different compared to my other
relatives because they were older than
me
so they had different experiments
different you know i was growing up when
my dad's business was actually starting
to work out and he was making money a
few months so we can now eat we can now
we'll go closer you can
go to school you know but if you ask my
other older relatives it was a different
story for them excuse me but
as far as growing up in tanzania
it wasn't easy
it was not easy at all
for me for my family
describe what it's like
okay so um a what perspective going on
like uh
just like electricity and water let's
start with okay so uh
growing up in
just africa
there's a lot of things that you know
you don't get access to one of the main
things that we never even had access to
was information
you don't even get information you don't
even get the right information
we have youtube out here we got facebook
you know you got a lot of google i mean
we do we do we do have them back there
too but you know
as far as growing up back then
you know
even right now feel me not even back
then because you know i'm just talking
about that one area but that's
that's why you know
uh
pretty much
a lot of things
you know
most of my childhood you know was
pain you know
you know just uh fear
you know uh how i always see it like
because you know my mind is different
you know i don't see myself as an
african kid doesn't none of the america
i just see myself as a child of god so i
always see myself as just growing up in
africa it's just you walk into some
[ __ ]
you know you just walked into some
straight [ __ ] you know like how i
saw it you know just growing up with my
family and my family was you know we i
grew up different i grew up where my
mom's side
didn't get along with my dad's side
i'm talking about real black fight you
know [ __ ] like that and
how i see it is like i was i was i was
just born to this [ __ ] no
i was just a kid i grew up in this thing
most young men like yourself right
staying in tanzania do they have hope
for their futures or are they just
hustlers most of the kids out there i
would say
there's very low hope
there's very low hope so that that means
they resort to what
violence
results to
i can't say drugs because you know we
have beliefs you know we grew up with
beliefs and traditions are there drugs
in tanzania of course there's drugs
everywhere in africa yeah
different type of drugs than you ever
seen out here
they make their own drugs
but uh talking about like
we have beliefs we have tradition you
know we have fear of god you know we're
african so you know we're raising these
traditions different from americans you
know we're raised with african women you
know
which we see them as our our gods you
know our living gods i always see my
mama's my living god you can ask that to
any black african young man we love
respect our mamas you know we have that
fear for mamas no
one of the biggest thing everybody says
i want to get my mama out the hood feel
me
we always had that so
some extent you know
we have that fear you know we have that
uh
tradition you know because you know you
still have your grandparents you still
have all that but
people are different at the same time i
cannot talk for everybody you know but
for a big percentage i cannot say like
um
africa and america like the drug problem
i would say it's worse out here the drug
problems
addiction is way worse
because i feel like
people are
there's so much that they've been
they're pressuring on the people feel me
that most people just
explode or find out an easy way out
or an escape
which is most of the time is the drops
feel me but back there
most people want to leave fema like i
told you know that's the only escape we
have is if
you just leave africa or you leave that
uh environment you're in you know no
matter what you're doing you can be the
richest person in africa man
you're still gonna go through it you're
still gonna have dirty roads you're
still gonna have you know
just
bad environment just feel me you're just
gonna wake up with skid row every day
and you're living good in your eyes but
you know the environment and i'm not
saying that it's not um
there's not rich people out there
there's a lot of rich people out there
millionaires feel me
but
at the same time
people don't really give a [ __ ]
everybody's focused on getting
the next bill
and the next bill
nobody really cares about
because you know
i have family in the village areas you
know
i
i used to go visit my grandparents you
know like i was this kid you know
my my dad you know would take us
maybe every now and then because i told
you this we grew up where you know my
dad moved where the money area is there
and he started doing his work out there
he moved my mom out there and it wasn't
easy for him too you know he back and
forth you know
left my mom with four kids
ran away you know this was before i was
even born you know that's what i told my
brothers had a different experience when
he had four kids with my mom he ran away
took off i wasn't even supposed to be
here
i don't know what happened what happened
in his head
they told him gotta be god
hey go back and you know when he went
back his business started working good
and everything started you know
going right but
for the most part
i wasn't even supposed to be here feel
me
because
he had four kids he didn't have nothing
to do with shining shoes and
he lost it you know
he ran away but at the same time
i had to be god
you'll be
because as soon as uh you know he had
his mind right and i
this is one of the things i wanted
i never knew what was in his head at
that time
and i never had a chance to talk to him
about it maybe that's all he said for me
because
i wanted to know why you know what came
in his mind what made him you know come
back you know but you know at the same
time he came back he had a focus and
ever since he had me
his life took off he did good made you
know better choices
and uh life changed
you know for as much as i remember but
then after he died
like i told you we have family problems
and you know africans and money
something
how do we crash how do the poor live in
tanzania oh it's bad
oh yeah my bad i went off topic but um
yeah i used to go visit my grandparents
in the village areas
when i said the village areas this is
where you know you see the animals
all the things you see in the movies the
lions you know this is where you know we
actually go in middle
come close with
you know all the wild animals you know
my grandparents used to hunt animals you
know
and i would see this
just
way of life that was now not right
and as a kid you know man i never wanted
to go back there because
it was dangerous for me you know just to
go visit him was dangerous
let me tell you this story right
it's one time we went back there we
never won that many times you know we
used to you know we're kids man we don't
want to go back there there's no power
there's no water we want to stay away
you don't want to play with our friends
and do the fun stuff you know so i never
used to want to go out there but now i
want to go out there but i want to help
them but at the same time
let me tell this story right so we're
going to visit our grandparents this is
crazy
it's the first time i met my um
like my my elderly grandparents you know
it was crazy because
they really lived in a village area like
i'm talking about
let's say a whole black right
it's full of family
not even a whole black let's say it can
be like three blocks
and everybody know each other it's all
family like my uncle lives here my
auntie lived there everybody lived there
and that was crazy for me but then
it's there it's like um they didn't have
water they didn't have power you know
and they were they were fine with that i
mean they've been living like that for
40 years 50 years plus my grandparents
is 80 years now
i just called him yesterday i'm like man
i'm getting your truck man you gotta at
least drive now man
you're getting too old man but they fit
though they've been forming their whole
life they've been eating healthy
eating organic food
they grew up their own food but it was
crazy for me because
funny story right
it's nighttime he's telling us all right
man bedtime he was telling us hey
this is not where you guys from like the
city areas
there's gonna be elephants gonna come
here at night
and we thought he was playing around he
was dead ass
i'm talking about who went to sleep and
um
we heard like the uh the house shaking
shaking and shaking
and we was like what is going on
that he just told us to be quiet
he used today so elephants come at night
and to pass through this is the village
this is the village area
this is real life elephants
no i don't wanna come here for that
and i was so scared
cause yo man imagine seeing an elephant
bro
just a real life elephant passing
through your window right now
a real life elephant bro
bro is
huge man
all he got to do is just do that man in
the whole house down
and we were shaking man i'm talking
about we were shaking i was i went to
bed i put my whole blanket on my head
i'm like no
put my earplugs i'm like no passed out
and it was real because the next morning
when we saw elephant footprints
feel me but he was so calm the whole
time i met him don't trip man they just
gonna go away but you know we never seen
this stuff
and we go the next day you know he shows
us like the uh
this wildlife you know this lions which
is
it's beautiful
it's a beautiful thing growing up around
that area you know but you know
it's like i don't know how to put it on
it's like the beautiful things are free
at the same time
because they didn't here they go they
don't have all these things they don't
have this clean water they have to go to
the of the river to get the water they
have to go farm for their own food
but their mind is so sharp they're uh
they're so strong
compare like
like my my grand my granddad
he's 80 years old he's so fit
i'm talking about his he's like he's
he's like lean he's healthy you know
you can find a 20 year old here man
man
he better die tomorrow man can't stand
up straight like it's crazy
like it's because of the food
the mentality is damaged you know it's a
lot of things
you know
so i always say like just
growing up out there you know
it's tricky cause
you don't know what's outside most
people don't even know outside of there
you know i'm feel so blessed you know
then i always want to take fully
advantage of this situation because i
have family that have never lived africa
they have never stepped foot out you
know
tanzania
you know
and that's crazy to me people thinking
like hey man
it's cause i'm in l.a and i'm
it's all this rainbow you know it's all
this beautiful thing that i'm living out
here well you got people outside out
here
what do you think of somebody living in
a tent
that has all these opportunities in
america but they
they're wasting it all
let me put it like this
this is for every african
who live out here
i'm not saying every because i'm not not
everybody has the same perspective but
we'll say the same thing
i'll say
it's comfortable
or maybe
he wants help he
i mean everybody needs help but
most of those people who are living in
tents they damage you know their
mentally now right i mean not everybody
i can't speak for everybody some of them
you never know their situation pretty
much it's it's the majority majority of
them right the damage feel me but i feel
like you know
if they can just clean themselves up
and get their mind strong
that's all
that's it just focus
everything else we just line up
once your mind is strong
that's you can do everything else if
your mind is weak
there's nothing you can do because
you're always going to feel a victim
you're always going to feel like why
this happened to me come somebody help
me this and that but as a as an african
man right you you didn't have the
opportunities these people did you
didn't have the you know never the
education you you you particularly
you you left came to america and you
have an education but i mean
particularly i had it i had a good
education yeah but but
majority of them yeah majority of them
even my friends i used to hang out with
me like i told you my dad was a was a
hard working person you know i would
never speak down on that he worked so
hard i never hanged out with him because
he worked so hard but
for the majority of people i cannot
speak the same you feel me for him
i always see like
god was walking through him feel me most
young men your age back in tanzania they
have no no education they have no
education and even if they do have
education
man this education is for fifth grade
education you know they don't teach you
like all the right things you mean they
don't
they don't
man in africa they're gonna teach you
about
computers we know computers they can
teach you about learning about computers
with no computers how like it's just
it's just different just as as much
as
education is so low
feel me
as much as uh
the teachers
feel me the wages people are not getting
paid man what would you want to go teach
and you're not you know not getting paid
feel me
personally i was lucky enough to study
the american system which is called
igcse
for most people
and i was i was lucky that you know he
made my he made me uh he gave me more
understanding as a young kid from africa
that's why i could visualize all these
things and i could uh i saw what was
wrong at a young age i knew what was
right and i knew what was wrong and i
knew
what was going on outside of you know
where we lived there most people
couldn't see that you know i love music
so i love music so much you know
it gave me like a
i was always you know
uh to see this new video new video what
a little wayne got what super you know i
love hip-hop so much so
which is i always see it as a you know
something that
made me at the same time
made me different from
you know
majority back home you mean
he gave me something like you know
to keep going you know most people don't
have some people do but you know
they're not provided with opportunities
to keep going what would you like to do
with your soul
yeah with your life
man
now what um
i would like to do
but what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna become
the greatest i've ever been i'm gonna
help my people at fully extent with not
just uh
not things i can give but knowledge i
can provide awareness there you know
this maybe the
the grass in green on that side as you
think it is maybe you know you're here
for a reason you know
and then um
as but as much as the youth you know
because uh
we are so like-minded back home you know
with uh
beliefs and traditional beliefs
that people think that it's always you
know
it's god well now no way you know like i
mean jesus will not you know
like
religion is so big in africa
so huge that
it's mind control for people feel me
and
africa is so damaged that you know
it's a jungle everybody's trying to eat
feel me
everybody you can't blame nobody you
know same way from out here you know you
can't blame nobody if you want to go
outside and you know
trying to you know
hustle you know to feed his family or
feel we cannot blame nobody we're not
giving opportunities you know people do
have opportunities out here
what is the problem what would be the
first step well in africa
personally
i think
the leaders
i think the leaders
i think the leaders gotta uh
they gotta change all the leaders
because
as i how i see it
most of the leaders out there before
they go help the people they got to help
themselves they got to help their family
that means uh taking money from the
people feel me that means uh
pretty much
putting your own brother down so you can
go up
you know
which
you can say man
everybody trying to make it you know to
everybody trying to feed their family
but
there's only few leaders in africa that
really care about the people
feeling very very
excited very few leaders
and
you don't hear about his leaders a lot
because
people are too busy
you know focus on the wrong leaders
because this is what the media portrays
and the focus is on feel me
i'll say this man
even out here man
a lot of people here talk like they care
about you know
their communities or black people or
or what's going on in the world but
most people
don't most people care about themselves
out here man even greed is everywhere
every [ __ ] way excuse my language
everywhere
and uh
if people can just come understand that
you know
we strengthen numbers you know
that uh love conquers all
you know uh
at the end of the day
you're really helping yourself you're
helping your kids you know
you're hoping the future
but people don't see that people see
right right now man i gotta you know do
this for right now if you mean i'm
having a kid tomorrow right now feel me
but
i don't always want to blame nobody
feel me
because if you think about it
no one really got the answers no one
really knows what you're supposed to do
feel me most people just told what they
told to do you know in school and then
leave school when they just lost feel me
you go outside right now
not every homeless you found out here
was you know
had a uh had a bad child who had a world
some of these people were bosses ceos
you know
some of these people were smart they
grew up in good families you know
they had good opportunities
you know
but it's just what life brought him and
i can have you know who am i to judge
him
feel me
i always see myself i'm not god i cannot
judge you and you cannot judge me either
and
but
i always feel like
there's something you can do man
there's something you can do feel me
gotta be something you can do man
you know i mean you're just not here to
just you know
come on man you can do something
you feel me
that's how i always feel i can do
something you mean i don't have much
when i grew up i came out here when i
was 18 by myself
and i'm looking good too
i have i don't have no relative out here
man
i work hard
that's the american way
you gotta work hard
nothing is given anyway man
people are thinking it's so bad out here
and this is la man
this is san francisco this is california
you know this is supposed to be you know
the top of the top most people coming
back you know where we come from both
sides fourth wall countries you know
and you come out here you just you know
you're giving this life that like
you just don't believe you know you what
you grew up seeing and what's really
going on is two different things feel me
it's like a movie it's like an actor in
a movie
feel me
you gonna think
which movie let's say uh
that's an animal with tom cruise right
he's not the dude playing mission
impossible feel me he's not uh like
when he leaves the set he's a different
type of person
he's not do you see in the movies
feel me he's not gonna jump on top of
the car he's not gonna do none of that
stuff
he's gonna go back home to his family
and his kids play golf
whatever you want to do feel me that's
him that's how pretty much you know it
was growing up you know
you see all this thing but it was
provided it was given to you when you
think man
if i can just get there man
all my dreams will come true
feel me man all this uh all these things
man i'm staying right there like flash
it like man if i can just get there
and you get there and you just find out
like
damn
[ __ ]
maybe it was good back then
it's interesting it's interesting to see
a young man who you're 25 and you and
your goal is to help
25 years old man my birthday was january
26 when kobe bryant died kobe
yeah but uh
i feel like
i feel like
for me
i had to change my mindset first feel me
i had to stop living as this victim you
know seeing that you know oh what is
happening to me
and just
try more to understand life
understand
you know like
why is this going on
why is this why am i going through this
you know
i had to change my mindset first and
understand
just a different different perspective
and that you know
that that helped me
that helped me uh
to help me understand better
to help me understand people
in higher classes lower classes middle
classes
every class better feel me
it opened my mind like
man
there's people really
living out here but then going through
it and people in africa man
and there's people living in africa
they're living really good then people
are here
and that's real life facts
feel me i had to understand that it
doesn't matter where you were
what matters is how
you act and how you
take advantage of where you're at
feel me you don't matter where where in
the world you're at they struggle
everywhere in the world
there's poor people everywhere in the
world there's rich people everywhere in
the world feel me
and that's that's true
feel me
as much as life is hard in africa it's
people making millions of money every
day
every day
and that's real
and it's not like they don't see the
other people who are going through you
know
bad you know the same way out here
people making millions of money is is
the wealth disparity greater in africa
than it is here i'm sorry what was that
is the difference between the wealthy
the rich and poor
it's greater in africa this for the
spread you're talking about the original
the difference between the rich and the
poor
oh yeah more i mean in africa obviously
there's more poor people feel me
because africa is big man
africa is huge bro yeah
and uh
compared uh to the mall is
i can say maybe like i don't know i'm
not really sure and no don't come for me
probably like 30 percent that people who
are really rich
and not that might be even more it might
be 20
you know it might be
maybe more 40 but i know for a fact
65 or 70 people are poor in africa
oh it can be less than that because you
know man
the pandemic in our life keeps on going
it's getting worse
feel me but at the same time
life is changing right now right now
people in africa it's not like how he
was back in the days you know we're
getting more knowledge you know there's
more opportunities coming you know
there's people helping out you know you
have people really and this is something
i really love from you know a lot of
people supporting people in north africa
you know you get more people
more white people come here and support
africa than black people out here see
more people having more fans out there
more funds like you know but
even in documentaries you see this on
youtube feel me these people talk about
all this they care and all these rare
all this my bad all these things to say
and act like they're really doing the
cameras but they don't man
you get these white people that go man
some of them they're not even that rich
they feel me
they just take a trip outstanding
and they change people's life out there
man
for the lord they have it can be man
person working at walgreens
fume
just get his checks together and he can
go back home and really make an impact
with those people man i do because i see
these blogs man i follow these people on
youtube see what they doing
and i respect that
feel me
i respect that man because most people
won't do it man
it doesn't matter even if you're black
or my color man
that doesn't apply to me man
it's your heart
feel me you can say all that man and all
this and preach all that but at the end
of the day it's your actions and your
heart
shoot me and that's what we stand on
all right
raphael thank you so much for sharing
your love thank you man appreciate it
how africa and america are different
yeah i wish you the best of luck thank
you sir thank you
you